lifting this restriction is just going
to make it worse for there's still
people dying every day I think the
government's first duty is the security
of its citizens and it's failed abject
lis still I'm scared and we people are
skate our community people are dying
neuen is the UK's worst affected borough
and on these streets there is a profound
fear of the virus Omar has lost his
father and his aunt to Co vid 19
including my dad there's another
gentleman on this road that passed away
gentleman I wrote down that my dad knew
personally and from one more where and
the elderly couple
two roads down when it first happened I
fought oh you know a few couple hundreds
have died it's not my dad not anyone I
know and then all of a sudden ears
someone you know so that's when you
realize like this is real this is a this
is a serious thing working at a rental
company
Omar is currently furloughed and is not
keen to go back I am scared
cuz it'll mother as well I'd only be the
one that goes to work and comes back and
she catches something off me and then
I've lost another parent but the
government is now considering how it
gets the country back to work and if
you've used a rational fear to encourage
people to stay at home how do you then
persuade people that it's okay to start
coming back out again especially in a
hard-hit area like this where people
have lost family and friends to the
virus so the government is turning to
behavioral scientists to help manage
this complex message it's a big problem
because at the moment I mean the
messaging is all about how absolutely
essential it is to stay at home and if
there's going to be a change in that
policy then I think what people need to
know is why is that why have things
changed testing contact tracing
encouraging people to wear masks at work
may help build confidence but we met
families in new erm who won't send kids
back to school
workers who won't return until the virus
is gone
all there's a vaccine Jamie is a
delivery driver I don't trust them
because they've mismanaged the their
whole policy from the beginning if the
government said look it's it's okay
under these circumstances these people
can go back to work and maybe delivery
drivers amongst them why wouldn't you
accept that that's because the
government said it was okay for the
Cheltenham Festival to go ahead and for
Spanish football fans to come into
Liverpool when they weren't allowed to
go to their own stadium in Madrid while
the lockdown has been a huge disruption
we've mostly complied but it could
actually be the easing of restrictions
where people are more inclined to rebel
Jason Farrell Sky News